SPEAKER: All righty.
That's so funny seeing
my face on there.
OK.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Alesandro Rodriguez.
And today, we'll be--
today, we'll be talking about
connecting to and preparing
data.
And so let's get
right into this,
and let me share my screen.
Yeah.
That should work out.
All right.
Oops.
Please excuse this.
And awesome.
So first off, I
just wanted to let
you guys know that under the
Tableau tab here under the--
under your their
home Canvas page,
you do have resources
here that will help you
with the exams and the
certification exam.
So for me, today, we'll be
going over some of these topics
underline-- the under
the connecting to
and preparing data.
So let's get right
into the show then on.
Let's see.
I believe what's present.
Awesome.
So connecting to
and preparing data.
The data we'll be using is
the sample superstore data.
So if you don't know
how to get connected on,
here's a quick little--
let's see.
So you go to your Tableau page.
And on right here,
under right here,
it's sample superstore data
is what we'll be using.
And voila.
Oh.
Taking a while to process.
OK.
Awesome.
So for our agenda today, we'll
be creating live connections
and extracts, creating and
managing the data model,
and we'll be managing
data properties.
So let's start off with creating
live connections and extracts.
So first off, live connections
are the default connection.
A live connection
is made when we
want our data to keep
flowing and the data
source from a dynamic database.
So when the database
is being updated.
So this allows real time updates
and up to the minute analysis.
And this is suited
for small to medium
sized database,
databases, or data sets,
or when you want real
time data updates.
And you can do larger data sets,
but they tend to be slower.
And then that leads us to--
let's see.
Let me move my--
let's do that.
OK.
So that leads us to
extract connections.
So extracts create
a static snapshot
of the data, which is an
unchanging representation
of the data at a
specific point in time,
reducing the load on the source
and improving performance.
Extracts are stored locally,
so in your computer memory.
And you can use--
you can choose specific
dimensions, measures,
and filters for the
extracts, which will be-- we
will touch on in a bit.
And as you can
see in the picture
here, it's located right here,
connection, live, and extract.
So let's show that right
now here for extract.
Let's move this.
Yeah.
So right here, we
have our live extract,
which we're all familiar with.
It's what we
usually do in class.
So if we click extract here,
we'll be able to edit it here.
And once we click Edit, we can
add like here, for example,
here a filter.
So for example, if we want
to do a filter on city.
And then you can choose
Allen or Aberdeen,
and that extract
will be included.
So awesome.
So let's go back to the
live one right here.
OK, cool.
And then we'll do like
a live versus extract.
So kind of a repeat here.
But a live connection directly
queries the data source
every time the
visualization is updated.
A live connection is
stored in the cloud
by Tableau, which is
more secure and reliable.
Extracts create a
static snapshot of time.
So basically, Tableau
copies the data source,
so say like the Excel file,
and uses it internally.
And extracts are
much faster and use
with more complex
visualizations and large data
sets as we touched on already.
And now, we'll be looking
at creating and managing
the data model.
So let's start off with
some vocab right now.
So first, we have
the logical layer.
This enables the user to join
the data using relationships
otherwise known as noodles.
So this right here is the
noodle, if you remember.
And this right here
is the logical layer.
And we'll explain what
our relationships.
So in Tableau,
relationships are a way
to connect tables within a data
source based on common fields.
So relationships are
distinct from joins,
and they are
particularly useful when
dealing with data that comes
from different databases or data
sources.
Relationships allow you to
establish logical connections
between tables without
physically combining the tables
into a single table,
which is what joint does
or what a join does.
And the way to do this is
to combine the primary key
of one table and the table--
and the other table that
contains the foreign key.
So the primary key is uniquely--
or the primary key uniquely
identifies each record
in the primary table, while the
foreign key in the related table
links back to the primary key.
So if the data source--
if a data sources have
different field names,
Tableau will ask the user to
define the matching columns.
So if we look here, if we
click on a noodle here,
you can see the relationship
that's happening here.
So we're doing-- we're
connecting region.
It's equal to region on this--
on this relationship right here.
And then sometimes it
does this automatically,
but you might want to always
check just in case to see
that if it did it correctly.
And sometimes it'll ask
you to do it manually too.
So yeah.
Let's move on.
So let's do more vocabulary.
Now, we have the
physical layer, which
is regarded as a
sub logical layer.
In order to access it, you need
a double click a logical table.
In the physical layer, you
are able to use joins, unions
by dragging another table
into blank space for joins
and on top of the
table for unions.
So you know it is a join if
it creates one of these Venn
diagrams, and then it's a
union if it looks like it's
kind of stacked on each other.
And we'll touch on that again.
So what are joins?
Joins in Tableau combine
fields from different tables
based on related column
on a related column.
Joins can be done in
the physical layer
by double clicking
on the logical table.
So the different types of
joins that Tableau supports,
we have, first off,
the inner join,
which retains only the matching
records from both tables.
So that'll be this
one right here.
Then we have our
left join, which
retains all records from
the left table and matching
records from the right table.
That'll be this one right here.
Then it's the opposite
for right join.
So it will retain all
records from the right table
and matching records
from the left table.
And then for a full outer join,
when you use a full outer join,
the result is a table
that contains all values
from both tables.
And on joins create
a horizontal data
combination, which creates
like a wider table.
And let's show you
guys right here then.
So let's just click on
the orders right here.
All righty.
So we double click.
And now, this is our logical
or our physical layer.
And let's just drag
people, for example.
So if you highlight
over it, you can see,
it says drag union or
drag table to union.
And then if you hover-- if
you hover it over here, like
in the blank space and just
drop it, it'll create the join,
the inner join here.
And if you click on
the Venn diagram,
it will give you the different
options of what you want to do.
So for example, we have
region equal to region here.
So let's get rid of it.
Oops.
All right.
Let's get rid of this.
Actually.
Yeah, that's fine.
Awesome.
So now, what are unions?
Unions is a way to
append the two data
connections with the matching
number of columns and data
types.
So this happens in
the physical layer
by double clicking
a logical table.
Unions are commonly used
when you have a data
split across multiple tables.
So perhaps the data is
distributed over time.
So monthly or yearly
tables as an example there.
And unlike joins,
unions vertically
stack the records from each
table, creating a longer table.
And we'll show you
that right here.
Let's see.
So as I mentioned here,
you can just drop it here.
And it has-- it creates like a
vertical stack here, which makes
it the table a lot longer.
And then if you want to edit it,
you just click this down arrow,
or I believe you
can right click.
Yeah, you can right click
or click the down arrow.
Edit union.
And then let's get
rid of returns.
Awesome.
So now, which connection
should you use?
So for relationships, you
can use a relationship
when the data is connected
through some common field.
And Tableau automatically
creates them
or creates the appropriate
joins unless the data field
name is different.
So that's when you'll
have to do it manually.
And joins use-- or I guess use
joins when combining fields
horizontally from different
tables, especially
when working with data from
distinct sources or databases.
And as for unions, use unions
when stacking records vertically
from tables with
matching structures,
such as combining time
series data or data
sets with similar formats.
Awesome.
And now, bringing data in.
So this is very important.
So in Tableau there,
I believe there
are two main ways-- there
are two main ways to bring
in and connect to data,
through the data source tab
and directly in a
worksheet on the Data tab.
So in the data source
tab, you bring in data
by clicking the add button
under the connections, which
is top left.
We use this if we want to
connect our new data set
with the old data set using
different types of connections
we talked about in the
previous slide here.
And as for worksheets,
you bring in data
in the worksheet by clicking
the Data tab at the top,
and then clicking
on new data source.
We use this if we
don't want our data,
the new data set, to
connect to the old data set.
So it'll be like
working with two--
for example, two different
Excel files and one worksheet
or per worksheet.
And from there, you can--
without them-- without them
being related in any way.
So now, let's show us-- let's
show how to do that here.
So I don't remember.
Let me make sure I--
OK, I got rid of the union.
Awesome.
So like I said, under the
Connections right here,
you have this Add button.
If you click the
Add button, it'll
give you different file types.
And from there, you
can choose a file.
And then you can do a
noodle, you can do a join,
you can do a union, and
whatever you'd like from there.
And then for-- on a worksheet,
in order to connect data,
you need to go up here.
And then there's like
a data tab right here.
Click Data.
Click New Data Source.
And from there, it gives
you these options again.
And you can choose
which you want to do.
So for example, let's
see if I can find
a quick data set we could use.
So let's go with--
let's go with this one.
Awesome.
So we open it.
And sometimes it'll be blank.
So I just bring in the
connection over here,
or the table, the sheet.
And from there, you can go here.
And as you can see now,
I have two different data
sets right here.
So we got this one, and then
we got the sample superstore.
You can choose which ones.
And these are in no way
connected to each other.
Whereas if I were
to do it on here,
then it would be
connected in some way.
Awesome.
Now, we'll be talking about
managing data properties.
So we'll be doing a little
quick exercise here.
Let's move this.
Awesome.
So in the data source, let's
rename the column customer name
to C name.
All righty.
So let's go to the data source.
And to rename things, you can
either right click a field here,
and they'll show you
the options Rename,
or you can click this down
arrow and also show you Rename.
So let's rename this to C name.
And then that should
be updated over here.
There we go.
In the customer name
and their profits.
That is a weird chart.
All righty.
Now, let's do it
in the worksheet.
So let's rename
order date to O date.
So we can do order
dates right here.
You can do the same.
Right click or click
the down arrow.
Let's go Rename.
And we can call this O date.
Awesome.
That is renamed.
And then that should be
automatically adjusted
in the data source as well, so.
And then let's-- in order to
reset the new renamed column,
we can go back, and let's see.
You can click on--
go to the data source, and
we can click on C name.
And it says reset
name right here
under the down arrow
and O date, reset name.
Awesome.
And now, for-- now, we're
going to assign an alias.
So in the worksheet, we're
going to give an allies
to any customer name.
So let's go to sheet one.
Go to customer name.
Then it shows
right here aliases.
And from here, let's
make this a bit bigger.
OK.
So let's pretend we want
to change Aaron here.
We're going to call him
with his initials AB.
Then we go with that.
Then once you do that,
you just click off here.
And it'll show like a
star sign right here
that says that it has an alias.
And now, there's a AB.
So we want to click OK.
You can see AB is
highlighted right here.
In order to remove the an alias,
we click Alias again, then
click clear aliases.
And it is back to normal.
Awesome.
Now, we'll be assigning roles
and changing data types.
So in the data source, we can
change the data type of a field
by clicking-- by
clicking on the icon.
So these right
here are the icons.
This is for strings.
This is for data type strings.
And this is a geographic ones.
And these ones
are called globes.
So let's say we
want to change it--
what they'll have here.
OK.
So let's change segment here
or the customer name will do.
Customer name to number
decimal or number whole.
That does not make sense at all,
but you get the point there.
I'll just convert it to null.
Let's put that back to string.
Or here.
Here's a good
example right here.
We click the globe.
Then we're going
to make it this--
let's make this a number whole.
And there we go.
You can see how that's updated.
And then also, for the
geographical stuff, you can go--
you can go under here,
geographical roles.
And then it has a different
options right here
you can choose from.
And I believe you can
do that on string types.
And you see, that has
geographical role right there.
And if we go to order
date, that won't have it.
OK.
Let's fix this.
OK, let's fix.
Sweet.
And then we can do
this in a worksheet
as well by changing the
data type of a field,
or you change the data type of
a field by clicking on the icon
or clicking down
on the down arrow
and selecting Change Data Type.
So like I said, you can
click the icon here,
and it'll show the
different types right here,
or we can click the down
arrow or right click, and--
well, give me a second.
The classroom lights
just turned off.
OK.
Where was I?
So we can click the
down arrow here,
and then we can go
under Change Data Type.
It'll show the same
things right there.
And then you have your
default properties as well.
And geographical role
is under here as well.
Sweet.
And now, we have our
types of connections.
So our main two are workbook
and packaged workbooks.
So a workbook or otherwise
known as the .twb is--
so basically, a workbook
holds one or more worksheets
plus zero more
dashboards and stories.
If they are shared, the receiver
cannot modify the worksheet
and does not have access
to the data source.
They simply-- or they can
simply see the visualization.
So basically, they can only
see what's this right here.
They cannot see this.
There are none of this.
They can just see
the visualization.
And that's where a
packaged workbook--
a packaged workbook is
a single zip file that
contains a workbook along with
any supporting local file data
and background images.
So this format is the best way
to package your work for sharing
with others who do not have
access to your original data
because it includes
the data source.
So it'll include-- basically
all of this basically, what
you see on my screen right
now, it'll include that.
And also, if you
make extracts over
here and add filters and
everything, such as that,
it will include that as well.
And then we have
bookmarks or the .tbm,
which bookmark contains a single
worksheet and are an easy way
to quickly share your work.
Extracts or so the hyper
is a Tableau extract
files have the hyper extension.
So extract files
are a local copy
of a subset or entire data set
that you can use to share data
with others when you need
to work offline and improve
performances.
And then as for--
and then we have the .tds,
which is a Tableau data source.
Data source files contains
all the necessary information
regarding a data
connection made in Tableau.
So the Tableau data
source file contains
all the required
information on setting up
a data connection
along with the metadata
or other specific
modifications made by the user.
Sweet.
So that's all, folks.
So thank you very much.
Here, we have the other
TA led review sessions.
On November 29, well, at
7:30 in Huntsman Hall 260,
we'll have Tableau
concepts with Drake.
November 30, 3:30 PM,
Huntsman Hall 370,
we'll be exploring and
analyzing data with Katherine.
And then December 6, 3:00
PM, Huntsman Hall 323d 322,
sharing--
we'll have JC and
her presentation
on sharing insights.
And if you have any
questions, my office hours
are live from 7:00 PM
to 8:30 on Thursdays.
And then on Fridays, they are
open from 6:00 PM to 7:30.
Sweet.
Thank you very much.
And I hope you all have
a good time or good luck
with your exams and everything.
So thank you.